let's get down to business to defeat
Grace Randolph are you kidding this
video I don't know what the punchline
there is hey YouTube this video is not
made for kids even though it totally is
how you do it I'm Greg I'm John we're
gonna watch the latest Mulan trailer
excited to check this out people so
right now YouTube is apparently clearing
up some stuff so they've been
unsubscribing a lot of people as of late
so if you guys can go ahead and
subscribe and click that notification
bell right now that would be great
there's been some messages I've been
getting let's watch this trailer do you
know why the fees
[Music]
so get married you think the cool
female Phil in Battersea young from rush
hour one effort no problem
that's really look like a guy Darian we
are
okay Jason scholarly
well new kind of villain we got here or
is that a move on sprint
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
looks like they showed her plenty of
mercy there at the end I don't know no
they just cut out the shots where
they're executing her you want to put
that in the trailer and wanted to go for
a more realistic version hey man we're a
bunch of idiots we've got this obvious
woman with a cut all the time and even
those cut off her head she was
instrumental in helping us have that do
Jason Scott Lee man and that the villain
here every marginally Asian actor is
gonna be in this movie
well Jason Scott Lee no no Jason Scott
Lee played Mowgli yeah a live action
version of Jungle Book and now he's back
in the Disney World
excited for him to do this Donnie and
showing up I like that rendition that
they have of the the Mulan song playing
over here with that epic orchestral type
of tune to it saying that you don't
worry this is still Disney yeah well
even though we're going for a little bit
more you know realism and accuracy to
some sort of degree even though nobody's
gonna sing these songs we're gonna
remind you about yeah and so now that we
got because I know they changed the
names of everyone yeah she's not paying
in this movie well they have the so I
got the villain and now they have a
female villain to counterpart it that
way we can have a showdown with two
women yeah I'm imagining Jason Scott Lee
and Donnie Yen are gonna fight at the
end of this one near the two dudes
coherence each other and the two women
go down against each I mean one will
have to fight everyone and maybe Jason
Scott Lee Lonnie to her he'll I don't
know I don't think so maybe Mulan is
gonna turn maybe they're gonna have a
bird fight because I think that witch is
gonna turn into that Hawk thing so maybe
Mulan will turn into the Phoenix yeah
then I'll fight in midair and some kind
of CG battle the best way I could
describe how I'm feeling about this
especially with the way this trailer
communicated the movie to me is it feels
like an adaptation of the
as opposed to a live-action remake of
the movie yeah because the other ones
feel like that's the cartoon you know
and then this one seems these are the
same plop beat she's getting they're
putting the makeup on her she's you know
getting ready to I don't know the proper
terminology but at the beginning of the
Mulan movie when she's been tomato she's
doing all the whole matchmaker that's
the word I'm looking for
yeah a little matchmaker thing soldier
show up dad's like I gotta go join the
army and then she goes in his place
falls in love with commander Donnie Yen
that's the character's name in the
animated movie it's all going through
the same beats basically but the it's
I'm not hearing all the lines and the
tone and the vibe are not the animated
film so I'm liking the adaptation
approach that they're taking with this
but I am pissed there's no Mu Shu can't
let that one go I will never got that go
Eddie Murphy's back you know what's the
excuse now especially with Dolomites is
my name Zak reaching all the children
out there family-friendly I'm a little
bit upset that they didn't bother to ask
Eddie Murphy to reprise his role at
least give him a cameo no Alisa is
keeping it under wraps Eddie Murphy you
can he's gonna rap not for the
innominate issue I want there to be like
I'm sweeping shot at the army and like
perfume and oh man I am forgetting this
lead actresses name who has had no
controversy in the news that all they
know but I am loving her subtle
performance that we're getting so far
the teases that were getting to it this
looks this looks like the first Disney
adaptation live-action one that could
have this level of prestige to it yeah
well the thing about this one to me that
strikes me is kind of different is that
yeah while this is reminiscent and it is
re obviously move on I'm not thinking
the same way about it as I have about a
lot of the previous reboots it's not
going like oh look at this yet
transcription of this moment to
live-action it looks
like something akin to a Chinese epic
movie and yeah it's got the broad
strokes of the story but it sounds like
they're gonna change enough that I'm
sitting here curious about what they're
actually gonna bring to the scene this
seems like it could be more worthwhile
from an actual story translation
standpoint than a lot of the previous
ones they've done lately so like I was
happy to be sitting there during this
trailer reminded of Mulan but not
thinking of there's that moment and that
moment and that helmet so it might be
nice to have this movie kind of get out
of its own way with that and and show us
yeah kind of a new more authentic take
on this story that we all know
especially yeah well this still has some
of this fantastical elements to it yeah
I mean it's got like this Phoenix thing
and then all that stuff with a knee and
one character just straight up turned
into a Phoenix at one point a Dark
Phoenix and then in the Hockridge or
iago yeah because she's got like the
Talon hand on a set Iago Iago ah
do you know yog oh yeah from you know
from Aladdin he's the parent yeah yo go
animation here and the live-action look
kind of similar oh yeah that's right I
was I was trying to go down hey I'm
excited for this well guys what did you
think of this Mulan trailer are you
excited for this film do you think it'll
be the best live-action Disney
adaptation that's ever been done comment
below you guys can subscribe to the reel
rejects please click that notification
brother getting notified whenever we got
a YouTube video well make sure to hit
that like button or the dislike button I
don't care last but not least I like to
end this with a patron today shout out
to a man named JT the man from Huck why
II that's good that's because he's Asian
right you're gonna do another Asian
guy's shout out well on until regional
we get another Asian patron who pledges
for the shout out we were to add more
Asian followers right now every time
there's some kind of Asian related video
JT's the man from Hawaii the Japanese
hey butters my ability is gonna get the
shoutout
you are official Asian subscriber look
JD there's a lot I can talk about with
you as a lake you recently went to a
film festival that was in Hawaii
he spent hundreds of dollars to go up
there he saw taiko ytt live John Woo oh
wow
was there whoo he had a great time and
he was like was well worth the money but
what I want to talk about is that Mulan
has Asian people you are Asian it's very
good you are getting a bananas like in
this video our point about all your hair
that is the way it works man to this
movie I mean people do that with me with
Latinos I'm like I'm ready now you know
what it feels like which I'm sure you've
already known what it felt like to be
[Laughter]